[Music]
on this Thursday night Canadians finally
on the way home relief as two planes
leave China for Canada I think it's
pretty reassuring and a third cruise
ship turns into a floating prison fiery
train derailment the incident prompting
new orders from Ottawa president Trump's
triumph we went through hell unfairly
did nothing wrong
he's reveling in his acquittal as
critics rain on his parade you're
impeached forever and poignant
performances I'm happy because I went
here young survivors of Isis harnessed
the healing power of music
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
one plane carrying Canadians is finally
on its way from Wuhan China tonight the
center of the new coronavirus outbreak
176 Canadians including children are on
their way home it's a plane chartered by
the Canadian government a second plane
an American flight had some spare seats
and offered them to Canada it is
expected to leave Wuhan soon all the
Canadians on board are expected to end
up in Trenton Ontario at a Canadian
Forces Base that is prepared to
quarantine them for 14 days there are
two new presumptive cases in British
Columbia tonight a man and a woman in
their 30s
both were visiting from Hebei province
and were in close contact with the
second confirmed case in British
Columbia there remains uncertainty about
how this virus spreads and today
Canada's chief public health officer
advised anyone who has been in whom a
province recently should self isolate
what we're recommending is for those
travelers from Hubei to salvus elates
from the 14 days after departure in case
they begin to develop symptoms and they
then will already be distant themselves
from others the evacuees on those
flights from hooha are expected to
arrive in Ontario tomorrow and public
health officials plus members of the
Canadian Forces say they'll keep them as
safe and comfortable as possible
throughout their quarantine as Mike look
at your reports they'll still have to go
through rigorous screening before they
can go home right now we're just anxious
to get on the flight I think you can't
see the smile behind his mask but you
can certainly hear the relief and Ben
Jiang's voice the days of waiting was
finally at the airport with his wife and
two kids getting ready to board the
Canadian government charter back home
the fact that the plane has landed it's
right in front of us I think it's pretty
reassuring that we'll be able to get to
go home Jiang said the process at the
airport was well organized with Chinese
officials giving them thermal scans and
asking them to fill out health
questionnaires it wasn't smooth sailing
for everyone though any Wang's family
was stopped at a police checkpoint when
the Canadian plane was delayed Wednesday
we decided not to turn around you just
stayed at this gas station parking lot
so we spend a night in a car that's
unpleasant experience to be honest
Meighan Millward got some good news she
wasn't sure her husband would be allowed
on the plane because he holds permanent
resident status not Canadian citizenship
but the whole family got on the flight
to Canada and on board each passenger is
being closely monitored by health
officials any passenger who falls ill on
the plane will be isolated on the plane
if it happens that person will be taken
to a Vancouver hospital when the
aircraft stops for refueling same goes
for the dozens of Canadians who managed
to get on an American plane all
Canadians will end up here at CFB
Trenton for a two-week quarantine the
National microbiology mobile lab will be
on site to test any symptomatic
travelers as for the rest of the
Canadians still in China a third
repatriation flight is in the works that
plane is currently scheduled to depart
one on the 10th of February and to land
back in Canada on the 11th of February
the only problem they're running out of
room at CFB Trenton and government
officials admit they're not sure where
passengers from that third flight will
go into quarantine Donna all right lots
to work out Michael couture in Ottawa
thanks it has now been 14 days since
some parts of China were first
quarantined and yet there are still new
cases every day the head of the World
Health Organization said today much
about the virus remains a mystery and
that experts still do not properly
understand its transmissibility or
severity to put it bluntly with
shadowboxing we need to bring this virus
out into the light so we can attack it
properly there are now more than 28,000
confirmed cases the vast majority in
China including a new born the youngest
case recorded so far at least 567 people
have died all but one of the deaths is
in China and thousands of people
enjoying vacations onboard cruise ships
are now held captive on them
they've been ordered to stay inside
their cabins for 14 days the diamond
princess carrying 3,700 people is in
Yokohama Harbor 20 people on board have
tested positive for the virus including
two Canadians on the world dream 3,600
passengers and crew or net quarantined
in Hong Kong harbour
eight have tested positive and a third
ship the Wester dam is at sea near
Taiwan with 2,300 people stranded on
board there are no confirmed cases on
that ship but it had made a stop in Hong
Kong and the owners say because of that
Japan is final destination has now
refused it permission to dock it
highlights the perils of contagious
disease on cruise ships Redman Shannon
explains how people are coping another
ten passengers removed from the diamond
princess among them two Canadians the
Japanese government is keeping thousands
on board including over 200 Canadians
reading watching television and just
trying to stay generally positive it's a
two week long quarantine
many passengers are demanding more
information of what happens when we
finally get back to the UK are we going
to be put in quarantine yet again for
another 14 days you know these are
questions I need answered given the
uncertainty with this coronavirus the
Canadian government isn't being
definitive if they have already been on
the ship for 14 days and we're well then
we don't expect that these individuals
will then be off a risk to the general
population in Hong Kong around 30
Canadians are stuck on this ship but no
cases are confirmed my understanding is
that they're screening passengers and
once the screening is completed
obviously we'll have a better picture as
to what kind of assistance we can
provide and what are the local health
authorities want to do and now a third
ship with several Canadians onboard is
stranded at sea near Taiwan with reports
of one suspected case Japan is joining
the list of countries that won't accept
the Wester Dam we're getting more
information for global news
and then from the captain directly we
don't know where we're going to end up
how long it's going to take to get there
and what arrangements we can make to get
home
the ship's owner says it's looking into
alternative plans Redman Shannon Global
News London in this country the Federal
Transport Minister has ordered freight
trains carrying crude and other
dangerous goods to slow down after
another fiery derailment in Saskatchewan
it happened just after 6:00 a.m. the CP
train was carrying crude oil 31 tankers
derailed near Guernsey Saskatchewan at
least 12 burst into flames people nearby
say it was like an inferno no one was
injured but highway 16 was closed in
both directions and people living nearby
we're told to leave it's the second time
in under two months that a train
carrying crude oil has derailed in that
area Transport Minister Marc Garneau has
imposed new speed restrictions of 40
kilometers an hour on trains hauling
more than 20 cars of dangerous goods mr.
speaker were indeed very concerned about
the derailment that occurred just
outside of Guernsey Saskatchewan this
morning and that is why I put in place a
ministerial order which is going to
reduce the speed of trains carrying
dangerous goods for the next 30 days as
we examine why these derailments are
happening the order goes into effect
Friday night Garneau though is urging
all provinces to implement the new limit
immediately the Transportation Safety
Board is investigating the derailment
the RCMP carried out a pre-dawn raid on
an indigenous camp in northern British
Columbia enforcing a court injunction
that required workers on a natural gas
pipeline to be given access to the site
it is based on the territory's
the police convoy rolled into its own
territory at around 3 a.m. protestors
say officers arrested six people at
kilometer 39 that's one of three camps
built by anti pipeline supporters
hereditary Chiefs of the WA so it nation
oppose construction of the coastal
gasoline pipeline through their
territories although elected leaders of
the First Nation have approved the work
it's a key part of the 40 billion dollar
LNG Canada project being developed in
Kitimat BC Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
is about to embark on nine days of
overseas travel he's going to Africa and
then to Europe and among the priorities
is getting support for Canada winning a
seat on the United Nations Security
Council our chief political
correspondent David akin will be
traveling with the Prime Minister David
well Donna Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
is traveling to Ethiopia this evening
where he will become the first Canadian
Prime Minister to attend an African
Union summit that's a twice a year
gathering of 54 African nations and
while strengthening the Canada Africa
relationship is a priority it will be a
secondary priority to winning African
votes at the United Nations Canada has
been a bit late to the game but the
strategy that has been adapted recently
has been the right strategy that is try
to mobilize and Mobileye the support
from the motel atra system and the
African Union is the place
Canada will stand or fall on its record
of engagement with the continent a
record that has been decidedly mixed
this so-called Trudeau charm offensive
will also have to overcome Canada's
on-again off-again commitment to peace
and security in the region south of the
Sahara stretching from Mali to Sudan
known as the Sahel the lack of sustained
engagement of Canada in the sand in the
past year or two may be an obstacle to
overcome in terms of convincing African
state that Canada is serious in terms of
its engagement towards the continent
nonetheless Canadian officials are quote
cautiously optimistic and they say that
regardless of the outcome of the
Security Council campaign they believe
this will be an excellent opportunity
for Canada signal that it is ready to be
a strong
partner with the African Union Donna all
right David akin in Ottawa Thanks he
could call it a victory lap by the
American president less than 24 hours
after being acquitted on impeachment
charges Donald Trump felt he needed to
settle some scores and he did it in a
stream of consciousness speech savaging
his political enemies who tried and
failed to remove him from office as
Jackson prosecco reports it could set
the tone for his 2020 election campaign
from the stately grandeur of the White
House President Donald Trump launched
into a vindictive profanity-laden tirade
against impeachment we went through hell
unfairly did nothing wrong did nothing
wrong but this is what the end result is
for more than an hour and with no hint
of contrition
he attacked those who tried to remove
him from office Nancy Pelosi is a
horrible person and there'd a laundry
list of grievances it was all vote they
made up facts it's been very unfair from
my family 21 years ago then President
Bill Clinton offered an apology to the
nation after his impeachment acquittal I
want to say again to the American people
how profoundly sorry I am Trump still
insists his scheme to pressure Ukraine
was right and he began his day at a
prayer breakfast where he mocked Mitt
Romney the lone Republican to vote for
his removal I am profoundly religious my
faith is at the heart of Who I am I
don't like people who use their faith as
justification for doing what they know
is wrong
while on Capitol Hill the woman who
successfully led the impeachment of a
president offered a stinging rebuke of
her own
you're never getting rid of that scar
and history will always record that you
were impeached impeachment may be over
but it's clear Trump is eyeing payback
in the form of a vicious campaign
against Democrats in 2020 and with near
unanimous Republican support for his
acquittal it's clear his supporters are
ready to back him in that fight Jackson
prosecco Global News Washington
hundreds of thousands of Syrians on the
run tonight coming up the new campaign
triggering an emergency meeting at the
UN
thousands of foreign fighters and their
families including dozens of Canadians
who joined the so-called Islamic state
are going on trial in Syria they're
being held by Kurdish forces who are fed
up waiting for countries to repatriate
them Syrian Kurdish authorities say the
trials will begin in March more than
1,000 men 4000 women and 8,000 children
from 53 countries are being detained
many accused of involvement in Isis
attacks they're being kept in makeshift
detention camps and prisons in Northeast
Syria and there are fears they are
becoming breeding grounds for more
extremism frontline Isis fighters face
sentences of up to 20 years and those
guilty of war crimes face life in prison
that's according to the Roja Information
Center an independent organization in
Northeast Syria many countries including
Canada have refused to repatriate their
citizens who fought with Isis and none
of the Canadians captured face charges
here in Canada although several have
acknowledged their involvement with Isis
during interviews with Global News the
UN Security Council held an emergency
session today deeply concerned about
what's happening in Eid Lib province in
Syria the Syrian regime is in the midst
of a devastating campaign to retake the
city and experts fear it's threatening
the worst death and displacement of
civilians since the Civil War began
Syrian tanks fired at rebel targets
today in northwestern adlib the Syrian
military offensive backed by Russian
airstrikes is emptied entire towns
hundreds of thousands of people are
fleeing heading towards Turkey's border
there have been several failed attempts
to cease fires including one brokered by
Russia and Turkey last month and the UN
now warns a humanik humanitarian
catastrophe is looming enid lib and
three million lives are at risk
data deja vu had the Canadian made
algorithm that saw the warning signs in
Wuhan
you are watching global national the
outbreak of this new corona virus has
led to all kinds of challenges from the
massive unprecedented quarantine in
China to travel restrictions and the
race to find a vaccine new technologies
like artificial intelligence are also
being used as Jeff sample reports a
Canadian AI company has developed an
early warning system that picked up the
first signs of the corona virus outbreak
on New Year's Eve more than a week
before world health officials warned of
a new virus a doctor in Toronto was
already sounding the alarm
we obviously at the moment did not
necessarily know this was gonna turn
into the next big outbreak but we knew
that it had parallels to Sarris the
infectious disease physician was on the
front lines of the SARS epidemic and
remembers colleagues getting sick and
patients dying we didn't even know what
it was until it showed up in our
hospitals and in our cities we weren't
anticipating its arrival we basically
reacted when it got here he's been
working ever since to build an early
warning system using artificial
intelligence who are mapping all this
information his algorithm analyzes tens
of thousands of websites every day in 65
languages looking for any mention of
more than a hundred different diseases
it then scans anonymized data from
millions of flights and cellphone
locations to determine how and where a
virus might spread then that's Wuhan the
capital there on December 31st the
algorithm identified a press release
from health officials in Wuhan about a
mysterious illness at a food market once
we did that within a few seconds it
analyzed the flight itineraries of
travelers to destinations around the
world and picked up the locations that
were the most likely next place for this
virus to spread that data was then
shared with health officials around the
world the amount of information and
sharing of data about diseases outbreaks
has changed dramatically this Canadian
professor at Harvard Medical School has
developed a similar tool which scans
social media posts looking for
information and misinformation if you
understand the kinds of rumors and
emerging about for instance coronavirus
public health can build campaigns to
help really educate the population and
researchers at the University of Toronto
have built a program to predict the
epidemics trajectory it tells us this
thing's still growing it tells us it
will continue to grow artificial
intelligence can't stop the spread but
for the first time it's providing an
important tool to monitor and respond to
a global outbreak Jeff sample Global
News Toronto raising their voice is next
the remarkable women who survive the
so-called Islamic state
a small choir is undertaking a
monumental challenge
they are OCD women from northern Iraq
driven from their homes and sold to
fighters from the so-called Islamic
state so many of their voices were
silenced but there are survivors and as
crystal go man singh explains they're
determined to keep their culture alive
it's an attention-grabbing start to a
performance marked by its simplicity and
grace they're bringing the music the
Yazidi people to new audiences dancing
for Baroness's and lords but over the
past week they have performed for the
prince of wales and an oxford university
trained eye to music and dancing I feel
happy and I'm proud of our music
preserving the religious and country
music of Yazidi people is a project of
the amar foundation for 8 months they've
been recording and cataloging the songs
the charity provides health care to
those in displacement camps in Iraq the
music project is helping survivors with
their mental well-being a method of
psychotherapy it helps us to digest our
difficult situation and atrocities that
were undertaken against us the Yazidi
people were attacked with unimaginable
brutality in 2014 Isis fighters
descended on Sinjar in northwestern Iraq
the UN called it a coordinated effort by
Isis to destroy non-believers girls and
young women such as
Rena's were sold as sex slaves men were
murdered through a translator she says
she wants to go back home to Sinjar to
go to school and to keep performing to
take care of me I get like I feel very
happy when I dance when I sing the 19
year old has a sweetness about her
equality Baroness Nicholson of
Winterbourne the host of the event is
drawn to they've come here
show people what can be done and to say
well CD we're alive were doing music
look after us support us the smiles and
laughter a sign of a successful trip the
ten young ladies will soon be back in
displacement camps in Iraq but they
leave having shared something
transformative misto commencing Global
News London and that is global national
for this Thursday I'm Donna Friesen
tonight's your Canada is Glover town
Newfoundland and Labrador we'd love to
see your Canada email it to viewers at
global national calm and thanks for
watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow bye
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]